humiliation we've all experienced it at
some point in our lives all we've done
it to others but why the point of
humiliating someone is to dehumanize
them to redefine them in other words to
rob them of their self perceived
identity and thus attack their power we
see these exchanges in parliament in the
news on television in sport and this
feeds the cycle of humiliation being
part of our culture we've normalized
humiliation if we feel humiliated by our
situation we seek a group of others to
blame and unfortunately humiliate where
did it begin where pack animals and so
to be socially attractive is important
to us embarrassment shame and
humiliation have a role in our evolution
if we have committed what could be
considered a foe path we show
embarrassment and then we're less likely
to be attacked by other members of the
tribe this is why we've blush when we
get Employee of the Month or are
otherwise singled out we're saying that
that embarrassment don't attack me shame
is something we feel for something we've
done and its purpose is similar
humiliation is done to us by others it
is embarrassment plus shame plus plus
plus and what the plus plus plus is
could be defined as loss of face we have
an idea of who we are what we like and
when this is challenged we can
experience a feeling have been
obliterated a sense of loss of self we
can even feel humiliated if a photograph
of ourselves is published and we have a
different image of ourselves than that
photo
the photo is a threat to how we want to
identify ourselves the usual scenario is
the Humiliator fears being humiliated or
already feels humiliated in powerless
and the way they seem to regain their
power is to take away power to harm the
identity of the person they see as their
persecutor men I believe have a
particularly tough time of it because
all over the world they have been
socialized to be strong brave competent
which usually means suppressing or
denying themselves vulnerable States as
part of how they identify themselves for
example a lot of men feel that in order
to identify a strong they can't be seen
to show fear grief or incompetence this
is a really difficult self-image to live
up to when a vulnerability is exposed by
someone it may be that the only way they
can regain their supposed power is to
resort to violence and maybe this
enculturation of the macho tough guy
being the only desirable image for a man
that's one of the reasons that men are
many times more violent and aggressive
than women but the violence rarely ends
anything it usually leads to more
humiliation and more violence we may
have a hunger for revenge and
humiliation is often a part of revenge
but the only way to redemption is to
build up our enemies not knock them down
this means for example giving prisoners
education training and therapy not more
punishment and therefore more
humiliation leading to more anger more
violence maybe we all need to be
humiliated about our habits of
humiliation
we need to readjust until we realize we
have been all too stupid lazy unthinking
and basically daft to carry on with this
winning and losing game will we dare to
be vulnerable and say if we don't know
the solutions yet but humiliation and
otherwise annihilating the enemy isn't
working we just might become les sept
ability Millie a ssin if we were not so
worried about how others see and
experience us let's let go of self-image
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon